a couple of nights ago we spoke to a
woman called marlena pavlos hackney
she's a restaurant owner from michigan
she came on the show
to tell us how authorities in michigan
the governor and the attorney general
were trying to send her to jail for
running her business
and she warned us that americans need to
fight against authoritarianism like this
where the united states will come to
resemble the country she fled decades
ago communist poland
we the people small business owners
like i told you we have to fight and i
will
fight for freedom for american people
and i encourage everyone
business owners other people stand up
and fight for your freedom before it's
gonna be taken away
we have an update for you tonight on
that story and it's a sad one marlena
pablo's hackney is
in jail she was arrested very early this
morning before 6 a.m by police
taken away in ankle shackles and wrist
cuffs
one of the few people in this country
gets up really early to go to work
because she really cares trying her
very hardest and they grabbed her and
they sent her away
for longer that people who commit gun
crimes in detroit get
we're told she will be in jail for 93
days unless she pays a 35
000 fine and the michigan board of
health deems it safe for her to be
released she's not going to pay she
shouldn't pay
molina's restaurant has also been
ordered closed until the michigan
state health department decides it can
open again by the way
when this happened the attorney general
of michigan who's completely out of
control and utterly political dana
nessel
issued a press release bragging that she
had been arrested like some
dangerous felon had been pulled off the
street
the county judge who did this rosemary
aquilina
defended the arrest saying that pablo's
hackney quote
has put the community at risk we're in
the middle of a pandemic by the way
they presented zero evidence that she
had any role in the pandemic
none no scientific evidence whatsoever
but they want you know that defiance is
the real
crime so people can come here from
foreign countries rush the border
sent out with no penalty whatsoever
whether or not they have covet doesn't
matter they're not even tested
they go right into your neighborhood
nobody cares but if you try
your level best your hardest to run a
business and do the right thing
you go to jail marlena pavlos hackney
remember the name we wish her well
we hope she gets out soon